BERMAN AND IT IS TUESDAY,
OCTOBER 12th.
BREAKING OVERNIGHT, JON GRUDEN
GONE AS HEAD COACH OF THE LAS
VEGAS RAIDERS, RESIGNING AFTER A
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT ABOUT
HOMOPHOBIC, MISOGYNISTIC AND
RACIST EMAILS HE SENT OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVEN YEARS.
>> THE EMAILS WERE DISCOVERED AS
PART OF A WORKPLACE MISCONDUCT
INVESTIGATION.
IN THEM, GRUDEN DENOUNCES THE
DRAFTING OF A GAY PLAYER AND
CALLS ARE FOR THE FIRING OF
PLAYERS WHO PROTEST THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM.
GRUDEN WHO WON A SUPER BOWL
NEARLY 20 YEARS AGO WITH THE
BUCCANEERS WAS IN YEAR FOUR OF A
TEN-YEAR $100 MILLION CONTRACT.
>> AND JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS
THIS IS RYAN RUSSELL, A FREE
AGENT DEFENSIVE END WHO PLAYED
WITH THE DALLAS COWBOYS AND THE
TAMPA BAY BUCCANEERS AND HE CAME
OUT AS BISEXUAL IN 2019.
LOOK, RYAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
I JUST WONDER WHAT YOUR REACTION
WAS WHEN YOU FIRST HEARD WHAT
GRUDEN HAD SAID.
>> MY FIRST REACTION WAS HEART
BREAK.
I MEAN, NO PLAYER -- NO PERSON
THAT LOVES FOOTBALL WANTS TO
HEAR THAT, THAT -- THE SPORT WE
LOVE AND THE ORGANIZATION THAT
IS HELD AT THE HIGHEST STANDARD
IS KIND OF REINFORCING AND
ALLOWING THIS BEHAVIOR, THIS
UNCOMFORTABILITY FOR PLAYERS,
FOR STAFF, FOR FANS, FOR VIEWERS
ALIKE.
AND I MEAN, SEVEN YEARS IS A
LONG TIME AND, YOU KNOW, GIVING
SOMEONE THAT LENGTH OF A
CONTRACT, THAT TYPE OF SUPPORT,
SOMEONE WHO IS KNOWN TO ME AND
OTHERS AS FOOTBALL ROYALTY IS
VERY DISTURBING, DISHEARTENING,
UPSETTING ON SO MANY LEVELS FOR
SO MANY PEOPLE.
>> SO HE RESIGNED.
AND I WONDER IF YOU THINK THAT
IS ENOUGH?
IS THAT ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOU?
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS ENOUGH.
I THINK IT IS REACTIVE OF THE
INVESTIGATION OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
I THINK THE NEXT STEP THAT THE
LEAGUE NEEDS TO TAKE IS BEING
PROACTIVE AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE COACHES THAT THEY HIRE, THE
PLAYERS THAT THEY DRAFT, THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY FORM ARE
BEING INCLUSIVE, ARE BEING
SUPPORTIVE AND ARE HELD TO THAT
STANDARD, NOT JUST WHEN THINGS
COME TO LIGHT, BUT ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S ACCOUNTABILITY.
DOING THE RIGHT THING WHEN NO
ONE IS LOOKING.
THE INTEGRITY LEVEL IS WHAT IS
BEING CHALLENGED HERE.
AND, YOU KNOW, JON GRUDEN WASN'T
SENTING THOSE EMAILS TO HIMSELF.
THERE WERE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
KNEW ABOUT IT, OTHER PEOPLE
INVOLVED ACROSS THE LEAGUE, AND
THIS WENT UNCHECKED FOR YEARS.
SO, NO, RESIGNING TO ME IS NOT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
IT IS SOMETHING REACTIVE AND
REALLY KIND OF MINIMAL IN THE
VERY LEAST THAT THE LEAGUE CAN
DO.
>> HE WAS SENDING THIS EMAIL TO
SOMEONE IN A LEADER POSITION AT
THE TIME WITH THE WASHINGTON
FOOTBALL TEAM.
GRUDEN HAS APOLOGIZED.
HE SAID, WELL, IN HIS WAY, I'M
CURIOUS WHAT YOU THOUGHT OF HIS
STATEMENT.
HE DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONTENT OF THE EMAILS, WHICH WE
SHOULD BE CLEAR, HE PRETTY MUCH
OFFENDED EVERYONE HERE, RIGHT?
BLACK PLAYERS, FEMALE REFEREES
THAT WOULD BE OFFENSIVE TO MANY
WOMEN IN GENERAL, TO GAY
PLAYERS, SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT DID
YOU MAKE OF HIM SAYING THAT HE
WAS SORRY IF HE HURT ANYONE.
>> I MEAN, THERE'S -- WE TALK
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY, THE LEVEL
OF ACCOUNTABILITY, THAT RIGHT
THERE IS BEING UNACCOUNTABLE.
YOU KNOW, HE DIDN'T INTEND TO
HURT ANYONE, HE'S SORRY IF HE
HURT ANYONE, THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE
AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE SEEN SO MUCH IN OUR
COUNTRY, WE HAVE SEEN SO MUCH IN
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE
WITH COLIN KAEPERNICK WITH THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT,
WITH CARL NASSIB COMING OUT AND
BEING A PLAYER ON HIS TEAM, THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY PLAYER TO TAKE
THE FIELD ON HIS TEAM.
AND TO SAY THAT HE DIDN'T MEAN
TO HURT ANYONE, HE'S SORRY.
THAT'S -- I MEAN, THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
YOU KNOW IN THIS DAY AND AGE
WHAT THOSE WORDS MEAN, WHAT THAT
SAYS TO YOUR CHARACTER WHAT THAT
SAYS TO YOUR ORGANIZATION, WHAT
THAT WILL DO TO YOUR LEGACY, AND
YOU HURT PEOPLE.
YOU HURT -- LIKE YOU SAID,
LITERALLY EVERYONE AND THERE IS
NO STATEMENT THAT YOU CAN PUT
OUT THAT WILL TAKE THAT BACK.
>> GRUDEN ALSO CALLED FOR THE
BLACK BALLING OF A KNEELING
PLAYER, RIGHT?
HE SPOKE OUT AGAINST TOLERANCE
OF PLAYERS.
BLACK PLAYERS PROTESTING DURING
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S WHY THE NFL
SETTLED WITH COLIN KAEPERNICK.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THAT SITUATION EXACTLY.
I WILL SAY THAT WE CAN COME TO
ASSUME THAT MORE PEOPLE IN THE
LEAGUE HAVE THE SAME LIKE
MINDSET THAT GRUDEN HAS SHOWED.
THE EMAIL ISN'T JUST THE RANTS
OF ONE PERSON TO NO ONE.
IT IS A CONVERSATION WITH
MULTIPLE PEOPLE, WITH SIMILAR
VIEWS, AND LEADERSHIP POSITIONS,
IN POSITIONS OF POWER IN THE
LEAGUE, AND THIS NEEDS TO BE
CHECKED.
NOT JUST FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
THE PUBLIC OPINION, BECAUSE WE
CAN'T CHANGE THE LEAGUE, BUT
INTERNALLY.
AND TO HEAR THAT PROTEST ABOUT
POLICE BRUTALITY, ABOUT LIVES,
ABOUT THE EQUALITY OF BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WOULD BE MET WITH FIRING, WITH
HOSTILITY, WITH ANGER IS EXACTLY
WHAT THOSE PROTESTS, EXACTLY
WHAT COLIN KAEPERNICK WAS
FIGHTING AGAINST AND WHAT WE ALL
NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT AND
REALLY SELF-EV$100 MILLION
CONTRACT.
IN A WRITTEN APOLOGY, HE SAYS HE
NEVER MEANT TOJOINING ME IS IAN
NFL INSIDER.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
I WANT TO READ THE STATEMENT
GRUDEN PUT OUT LAST NIGHT.
I'VE RESIGNED AS HEAD COACH OF
THE LAS VEGAS RAIDERS.
I LOVE THE RAIDERS.
I DO NOT WANT TO BE A
DISTRACTION.
THANK YOU TO THE PLAYERS,
COACHES, STAFF OF RAIDER NATION.
I'M SORRY.
I NEVER MEANT TO HURT ANYBODY.
I'M SORRY, I NEVER MEANT TO HURT
ANYBODY, IS DIFFERENT THAN, I'M
SORRY I WROTE MASOCHISTIC, YOU
KNOW, HOMOPHOBIC, RACIST THINGS.
WHAT IS YOUR MAIN TAKEAWAY FROM
THIS?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE, I'M SORRY
EVERYBODY FOUND OUT.
THAT'S A LOOSE TRANSLATION FOR
JON GRUDEN.
I TALKED TO A SOURCE IN THE ROOM
WHEN JON GRUDEN RESIGNED TO HIS
COACHING STAFF.
THEY DESCRIBED HIM AS HEARTFELT
AND SINCERE AND APOLOGETIC.
BUT IT WAS TOO LATE BY THAT
POINT.
THE STANCE THAT JON GRUDEN HAD
TAKEN OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PAST THREE DAYS, EVER SINCE
FIRST THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
AND THEN LATE YESTERDAY "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" CAME OUT WITH THESE
RACIST, HOMOPHOBIC, MASOCHISTIC
EMAILS, IT HAD BEEN DEFENSIVE.
JON GRUDEN WAS ASKED, FOR
INSTANCE, WHAT HE LEARNED WHEN
HIS EMAILS BECAME PUBLIC AND
DURING THE COURSE OF HIM BEING
CRITICIZED THE PAST COUPLE DAYS.
HE SAID HE LEARNED THINGS BUT
WAS NOT WILLING TO SHARE IT.
HE SAYS HE DOESN'T HAVE A RACIST
BONE IN HIS BODY.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DISCUSS IT
FURTHER.
IT WAS DEFENSIVE.
ESSENTIALLY, THE WAY THAT THIS
BROKE DOWN, THE NFL ACTUALLY
SENT THE CONTENTS OF THESE
EMAILS TO THE LAS VEGAS RAIDERS
ON FRIDAY AND THEN WAITED FOR
THEM TO ACT, WAITED FOR GRUDEN
TO ACT.
NOTHING REALLY HAPPENED UNTIL
THIS LATEST ARTICLE, THIS LATEST
BOMBSHELL FROM THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" ESSENTIALLY FORCED
EVERYONE'S HAND.
YEAH, I READ HIS APOLOGY LIKE
YOU READ HIS APOLOGY, WHICH IS,
I'M SORRY FOR THOSE I OFFENDED,
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY NOT THE RIGHT
TONE OR SENTIMENT AT ALL.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, THE RACIST
EMAIL, WHICH CAME TO LIGHT A FEW
DAYS AGO, USES RACIST TROPES,
BLATANTLY, TO DESCRIBE THE
PLAYERS UNICON HEAD.
THE MASOCHISTIC EMAILS
MENTION -- FIRST, HE SENDS
PICTURES OF NAKED WOMEN, BUT
ALSO TALKS ABOUT THERE SHOULDN'T
BE FEMALE REFS IN THE NFL.
THE HOMOPHOBIC STUFF, WE'RE NOT
PUTTING IT ON THE SCREEN BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO REPEAT IT, BUT
HE USES THE SLUR TO DESCRIBE THE
NFL COMMISSIONER HERE.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR THE NFL
WRIT LARGE, IAN.
ALL OF THIS, ALL OF THIS IS THE
TYPE OF STUFF THAT THE NFL HAS
BEEN TRYING TO BATTLE AS IT
TRIES TO CHANGE ITS IMAGE.
>> YEAH.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S RIGHT.
THE NFL OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAS BEEN MUCH MORE
DIVERSE, MUCH MORE INCLUSIVE,
AND MADE A POINT OF THAT, BEING
VERY OUTWARDLY OPEN ARMS
PUBLICLY.
THAT'S THE WAY THE NFL HAS BEEN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
IT HAS BEEN INTENTIONAL.
IT HAS BEEN NOTEWORTHY.
THIS IS AGAINST THAT.
I MEAN, EVERYTHING JON GRUDEN
STOOD FOR IN THOSE EMAILS THAT
WERE PRIVATE EMAILS SENT WHILE
HE WAS AT ESPN BUT CLEARLY
REPRESENTS WHO HE IS, GRUDEN
WAS, YOU KNOW, COMPLETELY
OPPOSITE OF EVERYTHING THE NFL
HAS TRIED TO STAND FOR.
HOW ABOUT THIS?
THE LAS VEGAS RAIDERS HAVE THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY PLAYER, CARL
NASSIB, TO PLAY IN A REGULAR
SEASON GAME.
HOW WOULD JON GRUDEN, AFTER
SENDING THAT HOMOPHOBIC EMAIL,
WITH PLAYERS KNOWING THAT'S WHAT
HE REALLY THINKS, HOW WOULD HE
STAND UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ROOM AND LEAD THIS GROUP OF MEN
WITH SEVERAL PEOPLE IN THAT
LOOKER ROOM KNOWING THAT,
PRIVATELY, HE MAKES FUN OF THEM
OR IS AGAINST THEM.
IT COULD NOT WORK.
THAT PARTIALLY EXPLAINS WHY JON
GRUDEN RESIGNED TO OWNER MARK
DAVIS AND THEN TO HIS STAFF LAST
NIGHT.
>> NASSIB, FIRST OPENLY GAY
PLAYER ON THE NFL ROSTER IN THE
REGULAR SEASON, HOW WOULD THAT
WORK OUT AFTER THE EMAILS CAME
TO LIGHT?
70% OF THE PLAYERS IN THE NFL
ARE BLACK.
HOW WOULD THEY FEEL AFTER SEEING
THE RACIST EMAIL THAT CAME TO
LIGHT EARLIER?
RANDY MOSS ON NFL NETWORK LAST
NIGHT, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
YOU COULD SEE THE EMOTION.
I WAS STRUCK BY HOW EMOTIONAL
THE PLAYERS ARE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE REACTION
TO THIS WILL BE AMONG THE
PLAYERS IN THE LEAGUE?
>> I MEAN, FROM THE PEOPLE I'VE
SPOKEN WITH, AND IT'S TOUGH TO
GAUGE WHAT SEVERAL THOUSAND
PEOPLE THINK, BUT I'VE SENSED
RELIEF, HONESTLY.
THIS IS A MAN WHO, YOU KNOW, I
KNOW PUBLICLY WAS ONE THING, AND
HE SORT OF SEEMED TO BE KIND OF
A JOVIAL, COOKY LEADER.
THESE EMAILS UNCOVERED THE REAL
THOUGHTS OF JON GRUDEN.
I THINK THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WONDERING, PLAYERS,
EXECUTIVES OF COLOR, MANY OF
WHOM I SPOKE TO LAST NIGHT,
COACHES OF COLOR, JUST HUMANS,
WE'RE JUST WONDERING, LIKE, IS
THIS PERSON GOING TO GET WHAT HE
DESERVES?
IS THERE GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY?
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO DO THIS?
EVEN IF HE DIDN'T WORK IN THE
NFL AT THE TIME, EVEN IF HE
WORKED AT ESPN, HOW IS THIS
VERY, VERY HIGH-PROFILE FACE OF
ONE OF THE MULTI-BILLION DOLLAR
FRANCHISES IN THE NFL, HOW IS
THIS ALLOWED?
I THINK WHEN JON GRUDEN
RESIGNED, SEVERAL OF THE PEOPLE
I SPOKE WITH SIMPLY SAID, "OKAY,
GOOD.
THIS IS WHAT IT SHOULD BE."
>> THE QUESTION IS, IS IT JUST
JON GRUDEN THOUGH?
IN 650,000 EMAILS, IT'S PART OF
AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM,
PATTERNS AND PRACTICES.
THAT'S HOW IT CAME TO LIGHT,
BECAUSE OF EMAILS HE WAS SENDING
TO AN OFFICIAL THERE.
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
POSSIBILITY IS THAT THERE WILL
BE OTHER PEOPLE WHO ENGAGED IN
THIS KIND OF DISCUSSION THAT THE
NFL MIGHT HAVE TO LOOK INTO?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION, AND
THAT'S SORT OF THE NEXT THING,
IS WHAT HAPPENS NOW WITH SO MANY
OF THESE EMAILS?
THERE WERE THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
EMAILS, BUT SO FEW WERE MADE
PUBLIC.
THE CONTENTS OF THE NFL'S